This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Sam.
Friends, Romans, Countrymen, lend me your ears.
Do you know where these famous words are from, Sam?
I think that's a speech by Mark Antony in William Shakespeare's play, Julius Caesar.
Wow, I'm impressed. Caesar has been assassinated and Mark Antony tries to persuade the crowd to
find his killers.
Using words to persuade people, giving them a good reason to do what you say or to accept your
argument is known as rhetoric. In this programme, we'll be hearing all about rhetoric,
and of course, learning some related vocabulary as well.
The art of rhetoric started with the ancient Greek philosophers.
Later, during the Roman Republic, politicians and statesmen used rhetoric in speeches
given to crowds in the public square.
Although technology has transformed the way we communicate since then,
the art of rhetoric is still alive today. Modern politicians may prefer
Twitter to the public square, but they still use persuasive language, including soundbites,
short sentences or phrases, giving a message in an easy to remember way.
We'll hear more soon, but first I have a question for you, Sam.
Roman politicians used many rhetorical tricks to persuade people,
including the Argumentum ad hominum, which was an attack on their opponent's moral character.
Another was called the Argumentum ad baculum.
But what did it mean? Was it A, an argument based on logic, B, an argument based on emotion,
or C, an argument based on the stick?
Well, to persuade someone, your argument needs to be logical, so I'll say A.
Okay, we'll find out the answer later. Whether you want someone to vote for you or to buy
what you're selling, rhetoric can make your message persuasive.
During his career in the advertising industry, Sam Tatum learned a lot about persuading people.
Here he explains the many uses of rhetoric to BBC World Service Program, the Y Factor.
Rhetoric is persuasive language. We use it to rally, to simplify the complex, to inspire an
influence, but it's important, I think, to identify what strategies might be influencing us more
than we think. By understanding the power of language and shaping perceptions,
we can start to say, I'm wondering why people are looking to be so concrete.
Are we trying to pull the all over our eyes of something that's far more complex than we actually
state? As well as persuading people, Sam Tatum says rhetoric can be used to rally,
to bring people together in support of a common goal. A recent example of this is the way politicians
called the coronavirus, our enemy. The words politicians choose and the way they use them can
influence us more than we think. Sam Tatum says we should question whether political rhetoric is
trying to pull the wool over our eyes, an informal way of saying trick or deceive us.
But in the age of 24 hour news updates and non-stocked Twitter has the skill of making a thoughtful
argument been lost. Here's Kendall Phillips, professor of political philosophy at Syracuse University,
speaking to BBC World Services, the why factor. It's also hard to analyze the argument or reasoning
of a tweet, because 280 characters is not a way for me to lay out a logical argument with a major
premise of minor premise and a conclusion. It's much easier to just use a two word phrase or hashtag
that usually ends up adding to that kind of polemical division between my side and their side.
Global problems involve complex issues which cannot be solved in 280 letters, the maximum length
of a tweet allowed by Twitter. According to Professor Kendall, we need logical arguments containing
a premise, something which you think is true, and you use as the basis for developing your idea
and a conclusion, your decision or plan of action based on carefully considering all the relevant facts.
For example, climate change is damaging the planet, that's a premise.
Therefore, we should act to stop it, that's a conclusion.
Few issues are simply black and white though, and this is a problem because Twitter debates are
often polemical, argued very strongly either for or against a particular opinion or idea.
If you believe passionately in something, you need to explain it to people in a way they understand,
and in ancient times rhetoric also meant building bridges between people and finding common ground.
Like those Romans you mentioned Neil. Yes, in my question I ask Sam for the meaning of the term
Argumentum Add Baculum. I guess it was an argument based on logic.
Which was the wrong answer I'm afraid. In fact, argumentum add baculum means
the argument with a stick, or in other words, hitting somebody with a stick until they agree with you.
I guess that's one way to win an argument. Okay, let's recap the vocabulary from the program,
starting with soundbite, a short sentence or phrase designed to stick in the memory.
When people rally together they unite to support a common goal.
To pull the wall over someone's eyes means to trick someone.
Logical arguments contain a premise, a truth used as the basis for developing an argument,
and a conclusion, a decision based on carefully considering all the relevant facts.
And finally, polemical means strongly attacking or defending an opinion or idea.
But there's no arguing the fact that once again our six minutes are up.
Goodbye for now. Bye.